Okay, Michael what's your answer?
>> It looks like, half of them are right and half of them are
wrong. So, the number of mismatches, is, two out of four or a half.
>> Right, that is exactly the right
answer ,because ,you got half of them right
and half of them wrong. But ,it assumes ,that your likely to see all four of
the examples, equally often. So, what if I told you, that, that's not in fact
the case. So ,here's another example of error for you. What if I told you that
each of the points, is, likely to be seen ,uh,
in different proportions and in fact in these particular proportions.
So you're going to see the first one ,half the time.
You're going to see the second one ,one 20th at
a time. You're also going to see the fourth one, one
20th at a time and you'll see the third one
,four tenths of the time. Alright, so you got it
Michael? One half, one 20th, four tenths and one twentieth.
>> Got it.